chickens have exploded in size over the  last 80 years  this was a chicken in 1957 and this is a  chicken in 2005. today's birds are more  than four times the size here's why  in the 1940s America held a series of  competitions for Farmers to create a  super breed of chicken one that was  faster growing bigger and therefore  cheaper for consumers the success of the  contest grows conclusively that it is  possible to breed chickens with Superior  meat type characteristics the result was  the broiler chicken which exists purely  for its meat and can only live supported  by human technology  this changed the relationship between  chickens and humans forever the total  mass of farmed chickens now exceeds that  of all other birds on the planet  combined and humans gobble so many  chickens that there are 23 billion of  them at any given time  but this type of selective breeding on a  global scale comes at a cost  [Music]